ce vendredi 13 mai s'est déroulée la
remise des prix du concours d'élevage
une action organisée par le département
à l'occasion de la foire de bras-panon
alarmant conseiller départemental
représenté la présidente nassimah dindar
il était accompagné de daniel gonthier
maire de la commune et de jean bernard
gonthier président de la chambre
d'agriculture pour remettre aux traits
éleveurs l'oréal récompense c'est la
vitrine c'est la maison des agriculteurs
depuis bientôt 45 ans même si nous
sommes à la 40e édition
c'est beaucoup de joie rendre hommage à
des agricultrices ya des agriculteurs
dans le cadre d'un projet qui est le
leur mais qui est aussi pouvoir vie et
donner de la nourriture de qualité aux
réunionnais les dorians chaque année les
meilleurs éleveurs locaux sont
récompensés dans huit catégories sur la
base de critères techniques de
production un concours qui permet au
département acteur majeur de la
politique agricole de valoriser le
travail accompli par ces professionnels
c'est pouvoir dire aux gens rien il ya
un côté les élus qui font la promesse
aux côtés des sculpteurs des planteurs
ils font un excellent travail et il faut
ensuite que la population
plus jamais
consomme ni calmement consommer pis on a
besoin la réunion
armes des gens
croire en leur pays croire qu culture en
novembre
mais ever est la meilleure façon au delà
du prix remis aujourd'hui c'est encore
et toujours de consommer local à un prix
qui représente une vraie reconnaissance
pour le travail accompli par ces
agriculteurs qui chaque jour mettent du
coeur à l'ouvragé
beaucoup de satisfaction j'ai été
agréablement surprise quand j'ai appris
que j'avais le premier prix de
productivité
ça montre qu'on est capable quand même
de faire du lait à la réunion
voilà aujourd'hui hommage et je donnais
la preuve qu'on peut le faire
c'est un encouragement si les prix de 10
ans à bahia ça m'a sorti de l'école à la
11 et ma foi j'ai travaillé une pipe et
enjoignent et avec pas affecté au
kursaal à 14 ans papa et philippe vacher
tirs mais on s'en va pas jusqu'à l'âge
peine trois ans pp et c'est de là que
après ça m'a rappelé
lagache moins pour cette 40e édition la
foire de bras-panon n'a pas perdu de son
attrait selon le maire de la commune le
bilan de l'événement est satisfaisant
plus de 130 mille entrées